meantime we have Benjamin gildura who
won this really beautiful game and is
now leading the tournament so
congratulations on your Victory we
really enjoyed looking at this game
thank you so much so can you please take
us to this game
yeah so I played CD4 which is
it was a surprise I was for him because
I play Anita 3D for E4 but in this
tournament I played City for the first
time
so he went E5 twice which I was
expecting that G3
yeah so the line is very interesting in
ITF series Bishop G2 C6
he didn't play this before I mean I I
didn't know that he was going to play
this but I knew this so Knight F3
e494 Queen B6
9v3
A5
this is not the main line but definitely
one of the best foreplay
why it should know it very well if
if uh if there is anything I'm not even
sure if it's an advantage so the
trapping your knight here yeah D3
A4 so was all of this still your
preparation yeah yeah it was done to
move
17. so now this 92 Bishop C5 Castle
and E3 is very good move there stairs
spring H1 9g4
Knight C3 and here I knew that Knight F2
is a move
and Rook have two Bishop of 294 and
I know that yeah
I believe Knight takes A4
sorry yeah oh okay and how would you
evaluate this position so anyway it's
slightly better for a while but I
believe it can be very unpleasant for
black because let's say queen A7
I'm not sure but
yeah there is some I have also some
development advantage and
yeah the nines are coming first like 34
34 Bishop D4 yeah four something like
that
it's very unpleasant to play so he
played crasso which was the best move
94 D5 very important move otherwise
black would be in a huge trouble
cd5
and yeah Bishop C1 so why is D5 an
important move if um so I've also this
is just another one let's say I develop
a piece
yeah that no I believe that A4 is
hanging but I think the point is that if
you go bishopter C1 immediately green
c193 then there is C5
and it ruins the the night
so that's why D5 is yeah
so 1945
Bishop C1 queen c193 and I knew that
there was a game
[Music]
yeah I remember the swedler game
which was Rook F3
id5
Queen theater I wasn't sure about Bishop
G4 I didn't recall that
what to do after Bishop G4
but yeah Iris and you have four I wasn't
completely sure about this because
easy and
I wasn't sure if I have an advantage
here
so where do you think your advantage is
is it more against this p-pawn or
playing against this King somehow so
both both playing on both sides so you
want to take on something like 96 yeah
but I wasn't completely sure if this is
yeah yeah you have quite a few so after
visual G4 I can also play other moves
like
Rook F1 or Rook F2 even
because Rook f2f5 Rook f
uck
yeah I was actually staying on D4 that's
a
possibility I believe before here yeah
and then point being give takes you take
everything and then a g for a second
but I wasn't home so used to sure if
it's an advantage the idea of you have I
have some initiative yeah yeah this
looks quite dangerous because looking at
it didn't seem like somehow it could be
so dangerous for like so right so when
well when were you out of preparation so
you said you know it is right it was the
first move and I remember that
there was a game
with Knight D7 I believe instead of
green d8
and 95 cd5 Knight C3
this is very similar to what you had in
the game night of circus
and the iPhone 7 on F6
and
yeah this is
this is what I remembered
yeah and you would be satisfied with
this position right it takes and again I
mean I knew that it's a slight Advantage
for that and usually this your strange
sacrifices are very unpleasant
so yeah I would definitely have grown
for this
so he played printed
I I believe he still knew this because
he played it very fast
Rook have fun seems natural and maybe he
was out of book at this point I wasn't
sure
he played Knight D7 it was logical tapes
there's Knight C3
and I was respect to United F6
[Music]
completely sure about this
and I'm gonna have four for example
five yeah
uh I was planning to go E4 instead of
Queen F4
and something like this I don't have
like an immediate a time but I have a
good I have good compensation
because of the wicking and you're yeah I
think I can see the future yeah but
first one as well exactly yeah so a lot
of your ideas are associated with the
sacrifice of F6 but instead it's funny
you did sacrifice on F6 so in the best
possible scenario so he went before and
then Knight D5
[Music]
so
so what was your reaction when you said
this move I mean I I was thinking about
this before he played D4
it looks very natural to go for this
deal for 95.96 but on the other hand I
saw that I have an itf6 which looked
extremely dangerous
I'm sure that he expected that but maybe
he didn't see
Bishop E4
yeah that's what we thought he missed
because
rookie Queen H6 F5 and this is just such
a beautiful move so what was his
reaction when you played this move
I assume he already saw it I already saw
it so before
but uh yeah definitely this looks very
unpleasant because
I not only threatened Bishop to yourself
five but also ruji for his
an idea or the threat
so that's why he had to take there was
no other move
do you think Brooklyn A5
yeah I was expecting this
group F3
I don't know what that is
we'll give oh the computer line
um I think the idea is to take on F5 and
not allow check so some kind of a
passing move but I think what you played
is more logical because yeah just I
think mate
yeah exactly and
I mean I know that the engine says like
plus sales but
it didn't look so obvious to me live
after grenade Queen H7 cleaner fit
life after rookie H6
there are so many moves for blacklight
I don't have like an immediate threat
maybe Roger G6 is I mean I was I was
planning to play Rouge series but
uh I was like black has so many moves
like E8 I was expecting that but then
green G7 and then
green juice
for example can show this
when's the queen so what was the move
that worried you the most
so I actually realized that Blacklist
just completely lost okay yeah because
we saw you on the screen and you look
like you're calculating really hard and
he looked kind of despondent because I
think he was also realizing that he's
losing so he must have had this some
point at this point probably already
thought everything that like I don't
have like an immediate threat to grenade
you can always go green with seven
and
maybe that is still losing but light is
not an immediate win and
but yeah it's very hard hard to defend
your juices and he played Rookery five
after Queen G5 yeah it's just completely
lost because I have green D6 which is
very important yeah so you stop the king
from running and
and now it's game over and you win this
game yeah and so now this puts you in
the first place so your closest Rivals
are Christopher and some Savion so this
game were likely to end in a draft so be
three-way tie and Benjamin bug was half
a point ahead so what do you think about
this position yeah I think he has some
chances to win so what it would be
Black's plan in this position
wait The Rook just went to H1 and then
it came back I thought his idea of this
Pawn was hanging that's why he came back
um
well I think just some long term like
Bishop there I don't know if some
brindisers I don't know we should be
seven
yeah
I don't know but it definitely looks
very good for black
and who do you play tomorrow I play ball
oh you play book so this might be a
championship game so if he wins then
you're in a must win position so you
will be with the black pieces you must
have a lot of experience playing foreign
because you're a Webster graduate yeah I
think I played him four times what's
your score against him award rules all
drones okay yeah every time I play Black
summer I guess okay yeah he's a very
rich player yeah I respect is just a lot
yeah that is why he's winning the
tournament or dating
so yeah I I expected would fight are you
did you graduate from Webster are you
I'm going to graduate this may oh this
may okay well congratulations on your
win and your upcoming graduation so
we'll be looking forward to your game
tomorrow for fighting for the
championship thank you and that was
Benjamin corduro winning his game